what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider interview Studio at Sundance
20124 I am lucky enough to be sitting
with the team behind in the Summers
first I will start by saying huge
congratulations on your film M heart was
full watching this it's really an
accomplishment especially for a feature
directorial debut so congratulations
thank you so much before we dig into the
movie I need to say a special thank you
to our wonderful sponsor filo filo has
us here supporting defendent film making
which we greatly appreciate they are
breaking barriers by putting the power
to Green Light movies in the hands of
creators and fans if you want to learn
more about filo and their Community
check out their website
film. all right Alexandre you're getting
my most difficult question of the bunch
today A lot of people are going to be
first learning about your movie through
the Festival so can you give us a brief
synopsis of the film oh god um yes so
it's a a story about two sisters that
visit their dad had in the summer and it
tracks them through many years of their
lives you nailed it I feel like I love
waiting for people's like Expressions to
turn when I'm like give me a synopsis
for the movie but that was perfect there
so I already emphasized feature
directorial debut here when you decide
you want to make your first feature what
did you think was step one to making it
happen making it a reality and then
ultimately is that a step that worked or
would you recommend something else to
aspiring filmmakers out there I mean I I
don't do any future thinking in general
so I I just wanted this is a story that
kind of came out really naturally and I
just wrote it and then got into the
right hands and just one step in front
of the next step and then the next step
I didn't really think about like how to
get it out in the world is just
something I wanted to tell what was the
the first piece that fell into place or
like the person who supported you that
made you think like we're really going
to do this now I think that would be
Alex and NIS in lexicon um so I met him
through a fellowship I did with the wga
in film nation and I sent him my script
and he loved it and he was like I want
to help you make this and he was the
first person who was like okay I'm like
maybe we're going to make this oh those
people are so important to find I love
it so again Alexandra's first uh feature
here I have a feeling that you are going
to make many many more in the future so
can you each tell me something about her
as a leader on the set and also an
actor's director that you are excited
for more actors to get to experience in
the
future I'll go first um I talked to
alisandra before we started shooting
about the fact that I can be a little
bit of an insecure actor if I don't get
any kind of feedback at all I'm like oh
my God I get in my head a little bit and
so just even a word from the director
being like some some kind of contact I
have that longing and so I expressed
that to her before we started the
process because she asked me um which
not all directors do and when we got to
set I cannot stress how comfortable
alisandra made me feel she made me feel
like I'm a better actor than I am like
she was like you are nailing it don't
worry okay what about this what about
like you you made me feel confident
enough that I was then able to
experiment and because I'm a relatively
young actor it's only my second feature
it was really meaningful to me to be
able to work with someone that helped me
build my confidence moving forward you
know that's such a beautiful answer
that's such an incredible quality to
have I I would say to very gracious very
brave
because to be a woman who is a writer
and director and to
have to be assertive and bold and
caring um it's a brave thing to do and
I'm incredibly proud of you and it's
just it's beautiful Alexandra is
is
Al yes we love her I would say openness
I think just even from the very first
day um our conversations around every
take it was just very open you're very
um curious as to what we thought you
know a moment could be um and that skill
of collaboration with an actor you know
cuz there's so many moving pieces
especially in your case where you know
some of these things are Loosely based
on reality um I was just in Wonder at
how open and calm you were in some
scenarios that were really like you know
tight tight timeline so very very
grateful for
that well then for me it's like I never
acted before so you can't imagine oh I
have questions about that I'm very
impressed no she she helped me a lot and
and also I saw in set because I I've
been in sets you know in videos and in
other stuff when I'm directing that it
can get hectic and crazy but she always
had time you know like she she and it's
difficult when everything is very
stressful to have that time or or at
least show the actor that we have the
time and you know take your time and
that that is important at least for me
that I was I'm starting and and with the
kids too you were great with the kids
like I saw you all the time with them
with it because that's difficult you
know and no you nail it yeah yeah it's
so seamless it's so seamless and with
the structure that you roll with that's
especially impressive Rene I want to go
back to this being your acting debut was
the itch to act always there and if not
why now and why this film like
I I never wanted to act before like my
mom is an actress back home like in
theaters you know she she she couldn't
live by being an actress because they're
they don't pay well so but I saw her I
remember seeing her so in my head I I
always had that you know about trying to
to to act but I don't know you know
while I was taking a shower you know
doing some sins by myself but when Alex
I'm writing a movie with Alex because
that's what I that I like you know
direct and so I'm writing a movie with
him and he invited me and I was you know
I was thinking about it it took me a
while not too much but you say yeah
let's do it and I read the script and I
liked it and then I started to feel
worried you know
and then I said it I'm going to do
it and but I was talking about this
yesterday like it but let's do it
well because that's the way you know you
can't say like a it I no I'm going
to do it well so I called two acting
coaches and they helped me at least to
understand the script better you know
English English is my second language so
it's even harder for me and Alexandra
also she gave me freedom to speak in
Spanish but I wanted to say to say a lot
of the lines in English you know most of
the time so I don't know it was a great
experience and and something that I felt
that I've been saying it but it's
because it's true is that things that I
feel while I'm singing in front of a
crowd that there's something here that
you feel I I started to feel it while I
was uh filming and and it feels great
you know something here that I don't
know I like it so many follow-ups can
you can you tell us the first moment you
got that feeling on this set was it a a
particular
scene ER there were different moments
you know that I that I
felt you know like right like thinking
fast like in the car accident you know
the scene was a little bit longer but I
remember that I was feeling like
so into the character and I was thinking
about my son H that he could be there
inside the car and yeah that was the
first time and I you know my connection
also was with my cousin who he just you
know is he was like my brother and he he
died like last year like two of them
they were my same age so I used that and
that part uh so yeah and and that
feeling I feel it when I sing I don't
know Latin americ or songs like that
that it's they're deep songs so yeah so
I think that's one of the dim incredibly
powerful stuff um Renee and Leo I'll
throw this question to you but anyone
feel free to jump in it just based on
what was in the production notes it gave
me the impression that you two are
probably the ones to direct this
question towards but what is it like
working with a director with a personal
connection to what your characters are
going through is there anything that
kind of enhances the collaboration when
you're working with someone who has you
know firsthand experience going through
that and also a willingness to share it
with with you two as artists and also
the
world yeah I mean the the story isn't
exactly autobiographical but it is
Loosely based on on Alexandra's life and
I think vieta is the Alesandra in the
film and you know from the first meeting
that we had together when we were
talking about certain challenging
aspects of vieta's life and their
relationship to their family I could
feel the truth of what was what your
history was as you were talking to me
because I think as artists we cultivate
an objective distance from the work in a
way you know it's like okay now it's a
script it's separate from me but because
we immediately connected I don't know at
just an energetic level I could feel the
emotionality bubbling up and even on set
there was this quality of like this
feeling underneath but you trying to
keep a professional CU you're directing
and in a way that's exactly what vieta
is doing vieta has this whole emotional
life underneath of you know loss of our
relationship changing over the years and
this feeling of of betrayal but also
loving you and guilt and shame and all
that but vietta is the one who's like no
I need to take care of my family I need
to bring them back together I need to
keep my little sister safe I need to
maybe call my dad out but maybe not he's
he's not ready yet I'm not sure so this
kind of objectiveness that vieta needs
to have alisandra was needing to have
that as an artist and so I was weirdly
able to just
mirror that experience and it worked I
think for the film um which was really
cool yeah anything no imagine it's her
father so it's it was very difficult to
try to to do that ER I ask her questions
but she all the time she make me feel
like comfortable I think like maybe the
the accident part that you passed
through that you know I asked you a few
questions but you told me that you
passed out when that happened and I was
like okay okay
so I don't know like I try to imagine to
put myself in in in the position of of
what she told me about her father and
that's what I did and I I tried to be as
natural and organic I could be you know
I mean it's just to cut in but for me it
was also important like we created the
characters together they're based on
something but you inhabiting the role
and made it something different same
thing with you and like every one of you
we had conversations I shared you some
of the things that it was based on but
then we're like we're making something
together it was a collaboration yeah
it's really you were very gracious in um
supporting us with information but at
the end we you kind of mesh and you
create something from from you know that
information and we put our hearts and
ourselves into it and and give the best
and as as pero was saying we give her um
Alexandra nod oh yeah the microphone
sorry guys we give Alexandra nod like
was it go was it okay and Alandra is oh
here's my favorite question about that
does she have a monitor dance like is
there is there something you can catch
her doing behind the monitor that
signals to you like I just crushed a
take okay well there's one thing you
look over I'm like trying to do it and
have this mic here hold the mic for me
for a second she's like this like the
monitor is right here I'm like do you
even see the image you're so close she's
like and then like mhm mhm yeah yeah we
got it we got it we got it very serious
like not actually excited seriously
excited but a nod the nod was you
know all you need all you need all you
need so there's a lot of exceptional
work in this movie every single
Department the Beating Heart of this
film though is the connection between
all of your characters so can you each
pinpoint a moment on set when a scene
partner gave you just what you need
maybe it helped you crush a tough scene
or find something in your own character
that you wouldn't have been able to
reach without
him our Dan scene was really important
to me o that was such a good moment yeah
it yeah it was a a really beautiful and
sincere moment between and I I felt you
and I felt myself um and that was really
beautiful thank you for that thank you
um and I with Leo um being in the water
park yeah
we um that was very organic for us and
and we had a lot of fun and um right
after we called cut we slid down the
slide and and then my extensions fell
out floating in the pool floating scary
and a small a small child in the corner
was like what is that and I was like oh
um but it was so funny and that was a
moment where I felt really connected and
I felt really present it just felt like
we were having a great time and we
became siblings I think that day yeah
absolutely I saw it on I got to be there
for a little bit and it was it looked
like so much fun it was also so hot so
it was like no acting required God no
one's no one's asked about the heat in
Cruz Mexico but you can feel it when you
watch it I'm surprised no one's asked
about the heat when we're all
freezing how was it being so warm now
that you're cold and and you know like
the the young girls like they help me a
lot way they were and also Alison she's
like meet Eva in a weird way she helped
me to
be an
but but the way she was
answering and
everything yeah yeah it came out like
there there were moments with I I only
got to be there a couple days but um
when that Yi scene yeah it's like you
know Allison both of you it was
beautiful sparring and there was so much
I was feeling from her across that table
I like it was so complicated she was
great and also Luciana shaving shaving
that that was beautiful beautiful and
she was so great like I felt like she
was my daughter you know Leslie you just
brought up that you only on set for a
couple days there's like no simple
answer to this but it's something I
always wonder and I think you do it
quite well here what is it like playing
a supporting character with limited
screen time where you are supporting the
main character's narrative but also
making sure that your character still
feels whole yeah that's a that's a dooy
I don't know what the secret sauce is to
that but you do it um it's having a an
amazing family it's having an amazing
amazing family on set that is welcoming
and that doesn't always happen I've been
saying it all day um but it was just so
beautiful to walk into that because I
was I really was only there for a few
days um I was under the understanding
that you know you the limited time to
get some of these really you know
important moments and it was so
beautiful I was was sharing with someone
else earlier the first day that I landed
the first night that I landed um you
know I was kind of getting I was like
all right where is everyone and was
eating and was eating and we um we met
up with him and he crammed in a small
car with two of our producers Sergio and
Lynette and myself in the back pulled
out his laptop and started showing me
dailies he's like your first day is is
tomorrow so like I just want you to feel
like you're you know what's happening
and are part of this m movie and I I had
never I've I've been um so fortunate to
work with amazing people um but it was
such a unique experience CU I I have so
much respect for you musically already
um but it was beautiful to have just
that intimate moment to be invited in in
a sense um and and yeah so it when when
that happens you kind of feel like
people are giving you the Liberty to
bring what you have to offer in a short
amount of time it's difficult but it's
also fun that's so true I hope everyone
has that experience on a set it's so
vital I'm going back to a follow-up
question that crossed my mind forever
ago it was something you brought up
Renee when you mentioned that uh you had
done some like scenes in the shower it
was just making me wonder for fun for
each of you when you were like growing
up dreaming of becoming an actor what
was the movie scene that you would
reenact the
most
D I mean I was I was just singing all
the time yeah we were singing in the
shower I was singing in the
shower H yeah Anita Anita and Westside
Story
America America most of the time I I
sing yeah yeah but but when I was a
kid yeah I don't know Superman you know
I'm old school so Superman was the guy
the one Rock Solid pick there yeah yes
Whitney in The Bodyguard come on now I
was um I was a child actor for a period
of time I was on Broadway and I didn't I
don't really remember this but my mom
reminds me that I learned everybody
else's part in the play and I would like
perform it and specifically like the men
and I love that for my little trans self
um but I was in this Tennessee Williams
play called cat noton roof and the lead
male character is this guy named brick
who's on crutches and so I had the
costume Department like give me a set of
crutches and I would go around like in
the southern accent like being brick
which is just drunk and depressed um so
yeah I don't know I think I dreamed of
being Leading Men as a kid love it love
it um very big question for you but
there's something in your director's
statement that that caught my eye here
you were saying I wrote the quote down
so I get it right while making the film
you kept asking can we make amends for
our missteps our words our actions or
will they forever Define us and then you
also went on to say the closer I get to
finishing this film The More I realize
that issue is with the question life is
far more complex given you made that
statement as you were finishing the film
it was making me wonder now that it's
done and you've sat and actually watched
it do you have more clarity on that
particular topic no um I think that's
probably the right answer yeah no I mean
I think life is just complex and you
never really understand what someone's
going through and I think part of making
this film for me was actually
understanding my father cuz after he
died I was so angry I had so much anger
towards him for all of the he did
and all the he put us through and
the mess that he left and so I think
making this film and wanting to make him
feel whole and and and big and and not
not shying away from the bad but also
embracing all the good made me love him
so much because it also made me realize
that my trauma is his trauma as well
like the car accident him up as
well um and so wow yeah so it was that
was been important for me it was like a
healing thing but I was like no the
answers are yeah just like yeah that was
therapy just from knowing that that was
the question that you were asking and
attempting to answer the whole way is
like that's beautiful well you're
sharing your story and your experiencing
and your experience processing it
through film will now wind up
influencing others the same way when
they sit down and watch it themselves so
thank you for sharing that with us in
the world um I will end with one more
group question it's our filo question
and as I said at the beginning it's a
company that's all about putting the
creative power in the hands of the
artist which I think this industry needs
to do more of so for each of you can you
recall a time when someone gave you
creative control when you maybe didn't
expect to get it even though you
deserved it wow whoa when someone gave
gave me creative control yeah when I can
you repeat it when you didn't expect to
get it but you I'm like a big believer
everybody deserves it someone the other
day emphasized the importance of
collaboration and the fact that
sometimes you need to defer to others
but I like you know in music like with
my
label I I always thought that they were
going to stop me ER creatively speaking
and but it was the opposite also you
have to I don't know in my case I think
that I I set it up you know like I I
this is the way I work and if you guys
want to be with me H and you want to
sign me this is the way it's going to be
and I set that up like since 2005 when I
first signed with
Sony and I have I'm free I can do
whatever I want whatever I want I can
you know I I have done so many crazy
stuff and they let me because they trust
me but they trust me because they they
can see that I know what I want to do
and this is the way I am and so that's
important to show the people that you're
going to work with and they're going to
invest money on you that you're sure
about what you want to do you know and
and you're not like well I don't know no
this is this is me and if you don't like
it I'm going to go somewhere else so
yeah and that's how I earned that so
good as it should be um I think for me
it's actually I came up as an editor so
and I think editors don't get the credit
they deserve because they really put the
film together and you know working with
other directors that really trusted me
as an editor and being being able to
like lead a story in that way made me
also a better collaborator CU you want
to hire people that can do their job and
can do it well and you have to obviously
it's a shared Vision but you don't have
to micromanage and so sometimes I'm like
I'm actually going to leave for a few
hours do whatever you think and then
we'll come back and we'll talk about it
you know and I think that's important to
kind of trust your collaborators looking
at this film and how it's structured and
knowing you have an editing background
makes all the sense in the world much
sense right so good um when I worked on
the flash uh it was a dream for me to do
all my stunts but I didn't think that I
was going to be able to do it um it was
my first film and I remember training
going in every single day and our stunt
coordinator Unice I remember she was
like up in these stairs and I looked up
at her and I said where's my stunt
double she's like you don't need one I
was like well don't we need one
legally and we did end up um having
someone there with usak but no but it
was my dream and I I trained so hard and
it was so amazing to have again it's so
amazing to have female leaders um um
it's just so beautiful because they
support and believe in your strength um
and Unice supported that the whole way
through and and that was something for
me that was I couldn't believe that I
was doing it and I ended up doing all my
stunts which was awesome for me you
crush that role Crush than you thank you
you already know thank you you already
know friend Leslie do you want to go or
you want me to go go okay um I think
something that was really cool about
this project is that vieta on the page
is written as a woman um
and you know when I was first brought
this project and got to meet with
Alexandra and talk about it you know I
described her I'm like hey there's a
scene where there's a sex scene and
there's intimacy and then we're at the
pool I'm a trans person who's had gender
affirming Top surgery I use they them
pronouns I'm very vocal about my
queerness and I want to be able to bring
some of that to the table and alisandra
immediately was like oh yeah of course
obviously and what was so cool about how
it all evolved is that even though I was
given the opportunity to sort of honor
the fullness of myself it didn't have to
become a plot point in the film and it
just it became a thing where okay vieta
we see her cut her hair when she's young
and then when we see her in their 20s
like they're living their most authentic
life they're thriving they look great
I'm like I love the Journey of the Two
Sisters um and so that was really cool
and in a way it's a kind of creative
control because it was an honoring of of
what I'm bringing uniquely to the part
um so I was really grateful for that yes
um well I would say I've had like I've
been fortunate to have multiple
experiences within music where you work
with people that are that are skilled at
collaborating and they allow you um
space to bring what you have to bring in
film as well but particularly with this
film I think back to your original
question because it was such a short
amount of time um and I felt like I was
coming into something that was already
there was momentum it was beautiful to
get that nod of not only validation but
um just appr like Liberty to hey like
make make Yenni yours like Ali and I had
many
conversations um a couple conversations
before you know we she started shooting
and uh and I got kind of an idea of who
Jenny was um but she was so open um and
then when I got to rehearse with you um
and your team it was was just I never
got to I never got to have that kind of
I don't know uh spontaneous um let's try
it out like we're in theater let's just
go for it you're such a great improviser
you know like that's what that's what
you do and you brought that to the set
and so to spar in that way was really I
didn't know I didn't know I I I was able
to do it but it was beautiful to be
challenged to to do it in this film I
love that question I love hearing
answers like that I must let you go so
you can continue promoting your film
getting at the widest possible audience
which it very much deserves huge
congratulations on in the Summers thank
you so much everybody out there thank
you for watching this interview keep an
eye out for the movie yourselves and
also for more interviews from Sundance
2024 and big thanks to
filmo